[Musique]
je me souviens de 2016 serrée
d'ouverture très émouvant extrêmement
émouvant en santé dans l'air une envie
désespéré deux états unis des américains
pour gagner la ryder cup et remettre un
peu de piment dans l'événement c'est qui
ma frappé le plus mon plus beau souvenir
c'était la beauté de la mise en scène de
l'événement tous ceux rouges qui étaient
partout était impressionnant même si on
soutient le bleu le peuple qu'il y avait
à la cérémonie d'ouverture à merci
derrière cette scène le fly over des
avions de combat américains
l'hymne national qui est déjà magnifique
mais qui qu'il a été encore plus beau
parce que vous aviez 40 personnes qui le
chante et en harmonie
donc oui les outils c'est un nouveau
benchmark au niveau de la puissance de
l'événement
[Musique]